les enfants donner le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes ce vendredi 13 juin pour la
journée olympique le rendez vous
organisé au stade mob auront de
versailles a réuni plus de 350 jeunes de
cm1 cm2 de la commune
l'occasion de découvrir de nouvelles
disciplines c'est pas dur d'apprendre
s'adapte très facilement justement de
plus on commence tôt et plus c'est
facile donc la non ils ont des réelles
capacités d'adaptation
on détecte un peu déjà les qualités de
pied les qualités d'impulsion les
enfants ont pu également s'essayer au
pentathlon moderne une épreuve composée
de cinq disciplines dont le tir au
pistolet qui s'organisait à versailles
pendant les jeux de paris 2024 après
quelques essais un premier verdict eh
bien on s'amuse
c'est une nouvelle navette dans la cible
tout le monde est content les élèves
l'enseignante j'ai essayé aussi c'est
moi d'être facile la concentration
savoir modérer son enthousiasme c'est
c'est très bien avec ces tests les
organisateurs espèrent susciter des
vocations chez les plus jeunes
versailles et objectif c'est évidemment
de l'est de les orienter vers cette
discipline pour pourquoi pas créer un
club à versailles et être vraiment dans
la course pour les pour les jeux
olympiques pour être dans la course pour
les jo versailles devraient de nouveau
organiser cette journée olympique tous
les ans jusqu'en 2024